many families of the 17 people killed in
the Parkland Florida School massacre are
applauding the arrest of former deputy
Scott Peterson who is accused of failing
to keep students safe Manuel Bojorquez
is outside more Marjory Stoneman Douglas
High School Manuel what does Pearson's
lawyers say well Tony his attorney calls
the charges politically motivated and
says they should be dismissed
immediately Peterson was the only armed
school resource officer here on campus
on the day of the shooting when parents
say he should have taken action instead
of taking cover it's a step towards more
accountability for let my daughter get
murdered after more than a year
demanding Scott Peterson be held
accountable following one of the
nation's worst school shootings loved
ones of the 17 students and staff killed
at Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School
expressed some relief on Tuesday it's
absolutely a nightmare and this is this
is the only thing we wanted for us what
we've been fighting for
Fred Gutenberg whose daughter Jamie died
tweeted following Peterson's arrest rot
in hell you could have saved some of the
17 Lauri al-hadith lost her daughter
Alisa it's very painful for me to know
that he had a gun he was supposed to to
act he had a duty tact that was his job
Peterson was charged following a 15
month investigation the 56 year old
faces eleven criminal counts including
child neglect culpable negligence and
perjury surveillance footage shows
Peterson never confronted the 19 year
old gunman during the February 2018
shooting instead a commission report
says he hid for about 48 minutes after
the first shots Peterson could be heard
radioing for backup during the rampage
there is a difference between cowardice
and criminal activity I think what you
found here is there are examples of both
in an interview a year ago Peterson said
he is not solely responsible I never had
a chance
I never thought even for a moment of
being scared or a coward because I was
just doing things the whole time
Peterson's attorney does not believe his
client can be prosecuted
on child neglect charges because he was
not quote a caregiver of the students
Peterson was booked in jail with bail
set at one hundred two thousand dollars
he is in the same jail actually as the
confessed shooter
Dana Manny just a bizarre coincidence
there with that thank you